welcome to tom pappas come to Papa
hey everybody welcome to another edition
of come to pop I hope you're doing well
this is a Thursday a Thursday edition of
come to Papa we've had some complaints
here at the compound that the levels of
our broadcast have been off and we aim
to correct it so we're putting out a
bonus episode of an interview that I did
with the great Jackie Kashian hilarious
comedian and all-around good person and
we're going to have our crackerjack
engineers here make sure that everything
is going well and that you're happy and
you know who you are
the people who have vocalized it and I
thank you for that so you will be
responsible for reporting back and
telling us how improved everything is
and if it is not improved we will be
taking our engineers out to the back and
digging the hole putting the minute and
burying them alive and then we'll find a
new one until we get this right I'm
going off to Bellevue Washington at
parlor live up near Seattle 13 minutes
outside of Seattle next weekend
Valentine's Day weekend you uh you stuck
you have someone that you like someone
that you live with something that you've
been with forever and you got to do
something you can't just let it slide
you have to do something during that
weekend I know it's stupid no one likes
planned intimacy but uh you got to do it
it's too much pressure and I am here to
alleviate that pressure come to my show
eat some chicken wings and nachos and
have a couple drinks and enjoy a show
for an hour and a half and I do all the
work you get all the credit on your way
out you say Happy Valley
tines day and you win and you're welcome
so come up to parlour live which is a
very good club you'll like it there and
we will like each other and I will stare
down your date
after that I'm coming the following week
I will be in New Jersey in Newark at
NJPAC very cool beautiful theater it's
almost sold out I believe so you're
gonna have to hustle on that one before
I hit NJPAC I'll be at Largo with come
to Papa live with Sarah Silverman and
Kirk Fox and bill burr and al Madrigal
and the great Rick chrome and the band
and myself I feel like I'm forgetting
somebody else Oh Melissa Villasenor
they're very talented
Melissa Villasenor will be there as well
so we have all these dates coming up
code is Han Papa calm and check them out
website is being redeveloped as well
there's a lot of construction hey look
it's a new year and it probably should
have been done in January but we're
organic we're getting on it also I will
be appearing on Conan in the very near
future I'm going to do Larry Wilmore
show the nightly show on February what
do you want to call it it's called the
24th it's a Thursday before I go up to
Boston and I'm gonna slide in and do
that show which is always funny and good
to do and I might also be doing
something with Bill Nye the Science Guy
that same day hmm
we're gonna have to get on that too
sweet Super Bowl coming up I saw a
recipe for layered nachos you know I'm a
nacho freak
but to layer them take a whole baking
pan and fill them up with layers of
stuff even for me that sounds a bit a
bit insane because you don't want to
just take two bites and then be out of
your nacho haze you want to
I'm gonna stretch it out you want to
make it last but how to do that that is
I guess that is the the solve isn't it
you make a giant vat of it everybody
else begs off but the thing is also you
know as you know with the nacho goes
quickly from heavenly nacho delight to a
giant scab in a plate afternoon all
coagulate so you don't want to um if you
can't get through it all maybe it stays
longer because it's in that hot thing
anybody have any tips anybody know any
layered nacho joys in their lives that
you want to share hit me up on Twitter
and Facebook and let me know okay so
that's the update for all the dates
that's the update for our lives I hope
you have a good weekend I hope you enjoy
the Superbowl and you should enjoy
you're an American and that doesn't mean
you have to like football at all
you actually can not like it at all and
just throw it on enjoy your life watch
the kitten bowl get some snacks kick
back a little bit your resolutions are
over go back to your old self and have a
good time okay before I choke I'm just
gonna queue up the rest of this and
we're going to go into Jackie Kashian
with our new levels there might be a
couple an extra introduction here with
the the old Bob Seger song but and will
reboot also it's a replay of Jackie
Kashian so but it's a nice message so
I'm gonna leave it alone and not mess
with it and we're just gonna roll right
into it enjoy a very fun conversation
with me and Jackie Kashian
come to Papa welcome to another edition
of come to Papa the most awesomest show
with most awesomest listeners I am your
host Tom papa hey everybody out there I
want to hear from you I'm always talking
to you I want you to talk back to me I
want you to tell me what you liked about
the show what guess you would like to
hear what random compliments you might
have for me go to Tom papa calm or hit
me through Facebook and Twitter at Tom
papa more and more people as I'm touring
around this beautiful country of ours
come up and bring up the show and they
always say that they're listening and
basically I want to take our
relationship to another level I think we
should talk more often I think you
should talk to me and then I'll
introduce you to my friends and you
introduce me to yours and maybe I'll
come to your town and we'll hang out
either in your home or at the bar or
I'll just run quickly to my car because
you look really strange but how do I
know if you look strange if you aren't
reaching out so go to Tom papa calm hit
me at Twitter and we will become friends
and I want to keep growing the show as
we go around and do the live come to
Papa's I'm gonna start taking it out to
different cities and why shouldn't it be
your city why shouldn't it and I'm not
saying big cities it could be a little
crappy town that you live in I'm sure
you have a school everyone has a school
and if there's a school there's a stage
and we can put on a show I am very
excited to welcome my guests today
they're very funny the very smart and
always positive force that is Jackie
Kashian hello and welcome to me hi Tom
papa hi Jackie Jackie and I first became
friends when I was playing in
Minneapolis years ago and we instantly
hit it off and became pals her stand-up
is hilarious incredibly truthful in her
material and her delivery when you watch
some comedians he always get the sense
that they're watching uh that you're
watching a rehearsed act both Jackie it
always feels very in the moment and
that's how she performs and that's how
she lives her life and why she makes her
so special you've seen her on Conan a
half-hour special on Comedy Central and
her latest release it's never going to
be broad
bread it's never gonna be bread I
thought it was broad and what's funny as
I wrote it down as instead of it's never
going to be bread I wrote it as tits
never going to be you know what if you
would named it that you would have sold
a lot more of them it was one of the top
ten albums on Amazon and she's a great
podcast called Jackie Kashian in the
dork forest her latest special this is
great we've been trying to get Jackie to
do the show for a long time and it works
out perfectly because on March 4th on
all things comedy calm you will be able
to get her latest special this will make
an excellent Horcrux and that is going
to be available probably one of those
five dollar deals that ideal five dollar
deal comedians giving away their stuff
for five bucks and you can get her as
this will make an excellent Horcrux
it'll be on all things comedy dot-com
good to see you Jackie good to see you
too glad we finally made it welcome to
my home thank you we did meet a thousand
generations ago it was a long time ago
hapless at the Acme comedy company I was
dating my wife current wasn't even
married yet right you were alone alone
alone you know you were I'm gonna say
hello you were single and on the prowl
and we went to go check out we went to
check out a like a midnight show oh I
think I brought you two balls overall
theater yeah Lesley Paul do they still
do that they still do do that yeah I
said do do still does balls Saturday
nights at the southern theater I think
in Minneapolis on Saturday between
midnight and 2:00 that's when the show
goes yeah and then they hang out and get
pizza until like 4:00 those days are
done but it is so kind no those days are
done for you yeah for me I'm just I'm
like 4:00 in the morning what am i doing
I you know this is that when you go on
the road do you do you blow out you come
back home early the next morning we're
like wait and take like the two o'clock
flight I haven't done on that because I
usually do come super early super early
and then I like to come home for some
reason bathe
get the road off of me nap for three
hours right then get up and have a nice
dinner with my husband right in your
home I do the same thing I go I take
right out
first flight home I'm always on it right
but I'll eat first I want to be back and
be with everybody and the other part is
if you don't take that first flight
that's when all the trouble starts and
the delays and you end up Oh Columbus
Ohio right right who wants to be but Kip
snipers but balls is a great show oh
yeah there's whenever you go I was in
Chicago recently and the second city
people they have a show later like 1
o'clock in the morning and you're like
all right so I'm has one right you have
all these great opportunities and that's
the one day like you don't have to get
up the next morning and do more shows
right and it would be cool to be like
you know what I'm taking the 4 o'clock
flight home so when my show is over I
can hang out with people and go to these
shows and perform in the extra cool hip
with the cool equals cool yeah with the
local cool kids and but my question to
you is that over for us are we just not
going to do that anymore because it's
slightly over feel like if I drank yeah
I still drank a lot you know I'd be like
oh yeah I'm up because I got to catch
the serious buzz and I might as well be
up till 4:00 in the morning yeah but I
can't drink like that and yeah so you're
off drinking well yeah I just yeah I'm
off
yeah yeah so it's but it's like I don't
know how to I don't know how to I wish
that I could I mean I don't know if is
that a young man's game
is it a twit 23 year old it kind of well
the other part of it is it's not just a
youth thing it's a hunger thing like you
are scraping like we want the stage to
we went and didn't the thing attacked me
and then ran over two balls and one
check that out and be part of that scene
and as you're trying to scrape your way
up mm-hmm and once you get to a certain
part where you're like okay I'm I'm
there and I'm do
it it's like I don't have it's like as a
comedian they say you just got to show
up the comedy clubs and hang out yeah a
spot but just hang out there's not a lot
of times I'm just walking into the Ice
House in Pasadena when I'm not working
just to sit there yep
you don't have to do those things right
I could strongarm my way onto almost any
open mic that's where my career is right
career I can just walk into an open mic
and they're like yes you you two can
have three minutes of that signing I do
have to buy something much like
everybody else yeah that's cuz open mics
we're hard on napkins comics are just
write setlist you know the other part of
it is that you have a you have a life
right you chase people in the house
oh maybe to see you come in recently and
when I say recently 10 years ago is what
I decided I would like a life yeah and
that is when the hanging out kind of
stopped that's when the drinking stop
that's when a lot of the things yeah I
was like let's let's have a rest of a
life as much as I love stand-up comedy
yeah and we'll do it into on my last
gasp I will be thinking you know like
you remember that I haven't heard it
recently but I've been thinking a lot
about how I know about being in a
relationship because of male comics
talking about their wives uh-huh so I
know how to be a wife by the things that
I'm not supposed to do because dudes
complaining about their wives one of the
things and I haven't heard it recently
this premise is there used to be a lot
of guys talking about how we were
totally asked and we're thinking about
right we thinking about we're not
thinking about anything stop asking us
that was the premise and then there
would be a punchline or there would not
but the weirdest thing and so I never
asked Andy my husband what he was
thinking about be great I was told not
to years ago we're in the car and he
asks me out of the blue what are you
thinking about uh
and I said comedy what are you thinking
about and he's a game designer and so he
goes games and it was the last time we
had
you kind of know what each other's
thinking about he will tell me what game
mechanics are broken at the jury system
or he went to his strip club the first
strip club ever he did win probably two
months ago
oh winter thing yeah it was and I have
been to several strip clubs cuz I've
been hanging out with dirtbag comics for
20 years right but he had never been cuz
every other bachelor party he had been
to I'm not even kidding
board game bachelor party things were
happening right there's a good time your
carcass on this is an awesome bachelor
party cuz we know our wives aren't gonna
let's play games anymore so he texted me
I was on the road I was in San Antonio
and he was he went to this wedding in
Chicago uh-huh and he texted me and he
said hey I'm just in time for the
bachelor party I'm gonna go look at some
boobs and I was like well enjoy spend
all the money or where you uh you
jealous a little bit was there any part
of you that was no I mean we all have
the internet if you I mean whatever I
wouldn't touch his keyboard on a dare
computers yes you have your own
yeah we've dueling desktops as a matter
of face each other you gotta come to the
door hobo yeah I know because I tape it
in my beautiful yeah lovely tract home
and I'll be around for the next month or
so
oh cool yeah come on over and Orkut
about some dork out about I don't know
I've often thought about it I'm not
really sure because you're the premise
of your thing dork forest yeah they
people have a thing in their life that
they dork out about you could pick
several like Tom Rhodes yesterday
recorded one with him he likes to visit
the graves of his heroes
that was a great thing nicked Apollo's
wife goes around just to not just her
heroes any famous people she goes to the
cemeteries and takes pictures next to
the tombstones
yeah she is like huge photo albums
filled with do you ask her like where is
but Abbot berries yeah like it's bright
it's over here and it's and she flipped
through and show you the picture pretty
awesome and she's not like a morbid
person she's very like yeah energetic
and positive person and she's has this
thing kira soltanovich was on talking
about how she goes to a Korean spa in
every city that she goes to a Koreans
Korean spa those are the rough ones yeah
those are the ones where they're bossy
they're super bossy Aaron's father like
take a shower make it a good one it's
the last time I went to a Korean like
okay all right ma'am is it worth going
to a Korean spa oh yeah first of all
it's cheap and it's deep tissue and they
they scrub your when you leave you have
super soft skin oh really they scrub on
you when they get up in your bidness
though you gotta be okay with him being
up in your business not in a positive
way more like a very clinical there's
nothing sexual about a Korean massage
and scrub I heard it hurts the pain of
the Korean oh so deep that it can hurt
and you can tell them yeah you gotta use
your words you know but I don't know
what I would do cause I've often thought
about I want to do your show yeah and
but you know my what do you like to read
I read a lot fiction nonfiction fiction
and nonfiction you really yeah short
stories are novels only Updike short
stories this new author who the 10th of
December he's a short story writers the
first one like since Updike then I was
like oh this is oh yeah okay we could
talk about books we could talk about
books because my whole life is literally
my career and your friend my family yeah
that's really all it is
that's it so do you don't go down a
rabbit hole and like you're not doing
flies in the basement no but I've got no
flies the garages just has cars in it I
often think about getting into trains I
like trains like we bring them out at
Christmas and we have them under the
tree and sure sure go to the train chop
and I'm like I'm gonna do this I should
I should make a village
it goes back into the attic and Ravin
speculate about it what you enjoy about
trains
alright that would be good that'll be a
good one it's an easy answer it's the
whistle but if you see over here under
the TV I have the the Xbox I have the
Kinect I have the Wii I have a
Playstation 2 these are games these are
all good intentions good dork intentions
where I'm like I am going to start
playing and then I don't is anyone
playing those games um my kids put like
hat shop sometime in there no my friend
I have a driving game okay but I don't
have video games yeah is it takes a
commitment in my the reason I've never
gotten and we have a ps3 and we have a
we love all these things because he's a
game designer right well the big game
the famous game that he designed I guess
many years ago was God of War 2 you know
that that's a big one yeah when he
worked at Sony Playstation he worked on
a lot of Wii and DS games at THQ right
um Locke's quest I think was a it was a
fort game and then and then recently
he's gotten into iPhone and iPad games
that's funny and now Facebook games and
pay right and you have you had actually
told me you had a little gaming problem
like you were playing it too much
oh middle management of Justice he did
not make that and then you were saying
that uh and you're like I you can't do
the console games anymore that you
backstage somewhere you had your phone
or your iPad out oh yeah and you're
playing some game oh they're all I mean
I and I was like do you do you this is
you you were kind of going at it like a
smoker does a cigarette there's always
like the one he's working on he just
worked on for Sony Pictures right sorry
everybody wants to get into the video
game design and like they're like oh
candy crush is huge yeah they're like
that is a fluke my friend right and but
this is called sword this is suits and
swords
your iPad Mini out yes and good for you
called the mini yeah yeah and it suits
and swords it's a it's a it's a
blackjack game right and you don't want
to split on a twenty turns out there's a
bird attack versus game it's also a
blackjack game oh it's blackjack and
then if you win and the bird gets hurt
sort out and and you you smack on the or
it turns out the bird beats the hell out
of you it's like that so that was what
that's the most recent game that he was
working on and then he's working on
games that are secret secret game he
can't even tell you he could tell me you
can't I do care because they're
fascinated what he loves
even more than video games yeah he loves
all games genuinely that is all he is
thinking about he loves board games
video games dress up like an elf game
wear a hat and talk like a pirate game
it doesn't matter
he wants to play it Paper Scissors rock
he's bored
is that good yeah actually is it's
actually very fun yeah the only thing
that drives me crazy is he won't be he
doesn't watch television because he
would rather play Magic the Gathering
don't you want to watch nine episodes of
Venture Brothers no okay
so I mean like a fun house it is fun I
mean and the thing is is I never had a
boyfriend and because all I did was a
prior to having comedy right which is
what I do I have comedy right I I just
read I just read read read read read I
was spooky reading girl right it's cool
and then and then stand-up comedy which
is its own rabbit hole yeah right that's
all you do all the time you're like and
then you hang out with comics and talk
about comedy the funny thing is is when
we'd have barbecues night up comics over
there'd be the comic side there'd be the
gamer side and the two conversations
yeah there they got on their own thing
and I got him a board game a solo board
game so that when I said that he could
play by like a solitaire
that if you wanted to play a game and I
didn't want to play a game he could go
play the game and then I loved it too
so we're kind of fighting over this out
there do have stacks of games in the
house oh yeah is it yeah like a lot of a
lot of games there's a board game gate
there's a new board game cafe here in
Los Angeles
oh yeah everything you know for $5.00
almost a thousand games you go and get
some sorry yeah sorry yeah but they have
much much better games than sorry
oh really have a weird they had a weird
we went once it's five bucks 11:00 a.m.
to 11:00 p.m. they have soup and
sandwiches and salads and coffee and
whatever and it's called game house a
che you asked with an for five bucks
should go they had a weird
we found this weird Korean Jenga game
where he hit so it's you but ax yeah and
you knock the bark off a tree it's
called but the cover of the box all it
said was over 10,000 sold in South Korea
South Korea exactly
I don't understand why games do you ever
play games with children yep you and is
that less enjoyable to you yeah I was I
find you're telling this I keep thinking
my kids are always asking to play games
I'm like all right let's do it
well that's because you're playing the
wrong games yeah do you have apples to
apples we have apples to apples you have
munchkin no you might also enjoy corkle
corkle is idiot Scrabble yeah I'm
terrible at Scrabble
I love Scrabble I'm constantly spelling
the word and and I'm not dumb I just
can't when I learned several letters I
can't put a word I can't you know good
epochal either oh my god I hate bugs
but corkle shapes and colors right and
and it's but it is also a little bit
trickier than that but little kids like
it because it's shapes and colors right
older and it's actually kind of
difficult and all the people who can't
spell like it right exactly cuz I'm like
oh I can find a square diamond
these things can happen where did you
meet where did you meet this guy online
online yep I it was I was on the onion
right and there was there was an ant I
thought it was the onions dating site at
least I'll meet somebody who likes those
would funny is yeah and he he was a
nerve which is some sort of softcore
porn thing it was an umbrella thing and
because the LA quickly was also in it
right and salon was also in it uh-huh
and so what you do is you would fill out
your profile right and put how many
miles you were willing to trip and I I
filled out a thing and I was on that
thing for a year and a half
Maria Bamford talked me into it oh
really yeah was she on it
no she was like you should do it
different dudes you did yeah there was
probably I mean I tried to count one
time did any of them go well some of
them were fine but that's the whole
thing is you meet and you go oh no
immediately immediately and then but
then what was the worst guy that you the
worst guy yeah this is not fair but here
we go yeah he was a he was a comedy
writer for a sitcom oh really and so we
were talking back forth he was
interesting he was funny and look weird
he didn't look weird he was perfectly
normal-looking dude because everybody
everybody's pretty fit in Los Angeles
yeah there's something on the wind and
so so he's like all right let's meet I
was like alright let's meet and I
usually do a coffee date right mm-hmm
and he was like well I don't really like
coffee and you want to go for drinks and
I was like if I could drink coffee I
don't drink booze just because I'm
really good at it you know I drink all
of the booze and then it's very
expensive for you
and then I like to get in my car and
then the police get involved so there's
all sorts of there's a train and they
set in motion that you don't wish to so
he was like well let's go to a dinner I
was like well that seems expensive but
okay we'll do it yeah then the last
email I get from him because he's like
should you do stand-up comedy and I was
like yeah and he said I hate stand-up
comedy and I said well this we probably
shouldn't meet then because that's what
I do and he was like no no I just I used
to do stand-up comedy and I just think
I've kind of bitter about it and I was
like whoa well so I show up he's like no
let's do it yeah we show up at a very
nice restaurant and he's already been
there
yes had a couple of drinks oh no and
it's raining right very rare but in Los
Angeles rain and we sit down we have
dinner and he doesn't get drunk but he
gets do he has four or five drinks oh
man that's plenty it's a lot it feels
like a lot to go a nanny at a glass of
wine with dinner and and then at 4:00
because I'm counting drinks because I'm
insane and he's talking and he's talking
about comedy and he's talking about this
and he's he's got a lot we're not
hitting it off yeah and and then at the
end of it the final straw by the way was
that it was raining and he told me he
had asked for a bag for his jacket
because he had just bought it jacket
you're supposed to wear the jacket and
he's hammered now no slightly and he's
slightly up in the air
yeah and that was a weird guy and then
another guy planted trees for a living I
thought oh I'm a giant hippie Skippy
dude oh yeah I I'm not a huge fan of a
dreamcatcher but I know what it is and
that guy I don't need us to go like the
first guy paid for everything right well
that's good and it was it was a lot but
and I and I felt sort of like we could
go I could get the tip
you know is there a part of you that's
like do I have to make out with them
right now do I have to slightly put out
just $120 that work do women really feel
and spend forty seven dollars right and
then is it the more you pay the more you
get I don't think so I mean for
especially but because I think that
there's that there's an agreement now
among adults where everyone's like well
the woman usually offers to go dutch at
least a part of it right I'll pay the
tip and but the the tree guy
we went dutch to a movie and dinner and
i was like you should have covered the
movie right yeah because he's a man
because of a gentleman i think that i
think there are sexism involved it's
natural that that he covers something
yeah just cuz i do it doesn't have to be
i had a friend of mine who started
dating again after she split up and yeah
she was going with this guy and she said
i had been a while and something wasn't
right she wasn't really I'm like
pressing her like what is it yeah the
sex bad what's going on and she's like I
know this sounds awful
in 2013 yeah but he doesn't pay for
stuff always split or I pay and he
doesn't do it and I got to admit it feel
he feels like less of a man to me
because it's weird and it's not it
doesn't have to be every time and you
yeah and you can go back and forth like
I when Andy and I started dating yeah he
would pay and then and then after about
the second or third date I was like let
me pay right and he was like okay right
and then you and then you would do
rock-paper-scissors and see who lost and
Cristobal oh he's really good he would
always win to come to pop on Sirius XM
99 I am here with my good pal Jackie
Kashian
she has a new stand-up comedy collection
coming out on March 4th at all things
comedy
calm it was called this will make an
excellent Horcrux where'd you get that
title that is that that is reference to
Harry Potter and and and a friend of my
husband's came up with it he is Steve
Mandell let's give a shout out to Steve
dv- Steve that's what he likes to go by
oh really is very negative and he hates
Aquaman so had he come up with the title
I don't know he just he said that
because I was talking about doing a new
a new CD and or DVD and I wanted and all
of these jokes are a lot more personal
and a lot more like I'm scrambling
around inside my own brain box uh-huh
and he said your soul and the Horcrux is
what Voldemort would hide parts of his
soul so he never died in the Harry
Potter series but then they got Lee died
at the end isn't it yeah you got to get
all the Horcruxes you got to kill all
the horror is that it's so funny
I've watched those all those movies with
my kids yeah and never really and
understanding what's going on I love it
I love them flying around they did a
nice job with it actually
yeah they played it pretty true oh it's
going the the books actually are better
than the movies even though I would say
of all the movies and I'm gonna make
some enemies here the first movie kind
of the best first one the best yeah I've
heard is is it popular the third one is
the best everyone thinks the third one's
the best everyone also thinks the third
book is the best Azkaban but say first I
say first just because they really the
way those children the way they capture
those kids right it was really great
right it really feels lying which in the
wardrobe II kind of yeah and I will say
that the book is the books are better
the books are better yeah what are you
reading now are you still reading are
you offer eating now Daniel day-lewis is
dad my Kaplan joke Daniel bad Lewis
Daniel day-lewis is dad whose name whose
nom de plume what his name was Cecil
day-lewis he was the poet laureate for
England from 1968 to 1972 aw really yeah
he in the 20s and 30s and 40s wrote pulp
mystery novels really and they are
fascinating
Wow how you even find this a fan of the
dork forest I think Vanessa I forget her
last name and from Austin Texas handed
me two of them in Austin Texas Wow
listeners hello you're the best yeah
they really are yeah and she handed me
these two books and he just needed money
really so they're pulp fiction and then
he fell in love with his own Agatha
Christie character
Nigel Strangeways is the name very well
written Wow and super smarty Magoo
references because he's a poet geez
and so he's really kind of slumming it
for a while really slumming it
and luckily explaining it to the not as
well educated education also one of
those people's but it makes me want to
be a better person
yeah I actually wrote down on my list in
in talking to you yeah oh no I didn't
even write it down
I guess I didn't have to I was going to
say but it was on my list was a life
because the one thing I admire about you
and you kind of alluded to it before was
that you all wanted another part of your
life attention in talking about your
husband but I got that even when you
were single when we first met you always
had like a real positive I'm enjoying
all the subtle you when you're with
comedians you're always in this kind of
space where people are doing their act
and then will offer that they're
wrestling around with them in their
careers and they're just kind of a
little angry and you know not all but
there's and if there even if they're
positive it's still all about their
careers which I probably a little guilty
of I think we all are but you always had
like a your eye on other stuff and
specifically yes one time we were
talking about movies and I was like I
don't know if this is that good and
you're like I don't know I'm sitting in
the dark there's moving pictures and
it's actually coming to life up on the
screen
how can I hate completely hate that I
always think about that isn't really
it's like the total opposite of the
hater mentality that exists something
they can't have it must come natural to
you
it must I mean I'm I feel actually quite
honestly very lucky that I'm not you
know how like there's a lot of people
that are depressed like clinically
depressed yeah and their synapses are
misfiring I've got to take they got to
take up the bill yeah and I am very
lucky
I do get depressed I get think it's sad
sometimes sure I'm alive right the for
the most part I am reminded you know you
don't know like that whole thing from
high school it gets better right and
then it gets worse yeah and then it gets
better again so you just have to know
that it does get better but then you're
gonna be bummed out again and then it's
gonna get better right and then you're
gonna get bummed out again are you
parents this way is this um is this um
it seems like a Garrison Keillor
Midwestern my father North Midwest
mentality I was raised with more
optimism than even made sense really it
didn't even make any sense
my father what my father what he loves
to say every day is a holiday every
meals of feast at bay with Elliott can't
be a bad day or something like that
just like that and you're like yeah I
can every day isn't a feast we're having
spam with crumpled potato chips on top
pop why is this a good thing you have a
gambling problem was he successful did
he have reason to not be that happy well
here's the thing about my dad is that
he's really really good at everything he
does
uh-huh but he also like as my brother
Russ likes deported he said you know dad
could have been fabulously wealthy
because he knows how to make money yeah
and he and my brother Russ is actually
very wealthy and very successful and he
said this is how I became successful
every time dad would say well this is
how you should do it I would do it like
that and then there would be a bag of
money at the end of the
and yeah and he said but Dad goes what
you want to do is you want to just do
this and then then you make a lot of
money and then there'd be this pause and
dad ago but what you really want to do
is a three pocket off the roof kind of
thing that's how I want to do it
92% of the time that fails right happy
because you've made it more complicated
it's too easy to do what was his career
he's excels many woman I'm siding right
how you know how Rodney Dangerfield very
much so yeah and went in men came out he
was furious
no really well now people are gonna
believe me when I tell them they're
gonna be on the cover of Life magazine
he's always working an angle like when
he turned 40 he started asking for the
senior discount and now that he is 75
years old the game has changed and he's
still positive
is he still my mother died last my
stepmother died last year you know very
sad but the first thing he said he said
you know I'm gonna die it was like his
first sign of mortality oh really he
goes you know I'm gonna die one day and
I said nice work making it about you
almost immediately pop and it's amazing
though I mean there's there's I mean why
not live that way yeah you know there's
absolutely he was he does this great
thing you know like there's a lot of
frugality in in Wisconsin and Minnesota
and right and everywhere everywhere that
isn't New York and LA right no we should
all of our own jet skis in Wisconsin
people are like well let's share a bass
boat with the neighbors
yeah and then everybody gets to go
fishing and there's there's a certain
frugality
it makes sense yeah and then there's a
frugality that doesn't I remember one of
my neighbors this is a great story
that's never worked on stage that's me
laugh every time my neighbor mrs. bridge
I went to a lovely New Year's Eve party
at her house right and then I didn't see
her for a couple of years and then I saw
her again and I go hey mrs. bridge I
just want to say I had a lovely time at
that New Year's Eve party that one time
and she was like and it had to be three
years later and she looks at me she
knows that was the year we had the
shrimp ring
I almost burst into tears I was like oh
my god she deserves whimpering every
year mrs. bridge yeah $14.99 over at the
grocery store with a little cocktail
sauce in the middle you should have it
on Thursday but there's something to
that there's that that's when it just
show up what it's a very special thing
my grandmother grew up during the
Depression yep and they went through
that thing where you know we had
absolutely nothing and everything for
the rest of her life was so special yeah
like it wasn't just an apple it was oh
this is the most delicious actually but
that's neat oh it was great I mean it
was great and I always am reminded of it
and try and have that perspective to
remember to be great yeah to be grateful
and to really enjoy all those things but
it's if you have been New York and LA a
lot of times you really it has to be
like a conscious oh yeah you really be
because we have so much yeah that when
and my and the thing is is the good
thing about it like my mother would
never let us use the Yahtzee paper who
we were saving was the Queen coming over
to play Yahtzee but my dad my dad was
like no no everybody deserves the good
thing you know you just heard the one
nice thing in his case it was a pinkie
ring nice suit but he took care of it it
was my wedding before when when my dad
and my husband were I overheard the
greatest conversation of my life which
was Andy loves shoes he says as a nice
he loves a nice red dress shoe and he
wears them every day really yes read
read always read oh is he bright red
bright red fire engine right like that
painting like that that red yep
that red hey red shoes red shoes and
they're usually like leather or
snakeskin or I mean something fancy Wow
I don't necessarily go with jeans but he
brings it off ready and cool it's those
are the shoes he loves and he was
telling my dad how hard it was to find a
new new pair for the wedding and and he
said I finally found these great shoes
but you know any any shows him the web
site he goes why are all where all the
models
why do black men have better shoes than
we do and my dad without missing a beat
goes because they take care of them
that's why and I don't even know what
that means except for that it feels true
really I mean did you find like when you
started showing up then you kind of
raised this way and you have this kind
of attitude when you start showing up in
comedy clubs and being around comedians
was it kind of a shock to you that these
people that make everybody laugh are
grumpy super the guys that I started out
with in Madison Wisconsin yeah seven of
us that's where you first went up that's
when I first went up it was owned by Sam
kinnison's brother Bill oh really yeah
and I he had it every night and it was
seven nights a week I did I got a one
point eight that semester oh it didn't
go well
luckily the club burn down but and then
I had to scramble to find open mics
because I don't know it was it like this
when you first started doing stand-up
like heroin no no no you didn't just
want to do it all the time once you
started doing it oh like I thought you
meant like in the scene was there a lot
of heroin around no oh there was
actually was Coke was comedy my heroin
yeah yeah absolutely
no there was no there was going back
yeah going back now you're like oh yeah
literally is an addiction genuine doing
stand-up is an addiction but love had to
burn down for me to graduate from I
didn't know he owned a club yeah it was
a it was a underneath I was on State
Street underneath this it was a den of
iniquity it was oh no and with Sam come
around I said I read on your website
that he was the first comic I ever saw
alive and you heckled him and I heckled
Sam Kinison terrible life choice Sam
Kinison is on stage and what do you do
are you try I'm drunk of course and I'm
19 I'm 19 and Andy and they and I had
never been out you know I was like it's
the first time I've been out it was the
first time I had been out
just playing by your own rules and all I
did and you know the worst thing in the
world is a woman heckler for women yes
so even if it's me it's exactly because
the audience still likes her better than
me they still have more sympathy for the
crazy drunk lady in the audience and so
it's a Sam's on stage and he said he was
from Peoria and I go sorry the worst and
this was right before he blew up and did
he turn oh he turned up being mopped up
the floor with me yeah and but I still
wouldn't shut up
because I was so drunk and finally the
manager came over and he was like you
have to shut up open mic is on and he
just in passing goes open mic is on
Sunday and just kidding right he's kind
of like seriously yeah shut up
open mic is on Sunday keep it together
and so three weeks later I came back I
show up and I do open mic and then I
never stop that's hilarious
yeah what a great start it's a it's a
hell of a start and then the club burns
down and you know how everybody has
their heckler story
yeah so the first bad heckler story is
Steve normal is the guy that I start
with right and there's five or six other
guys Honus Vinny
Jim ol ski a budget you know everybody
and it gets super competitive and super
like all that all the comics that are
playing this club are Comedy Store
comics from 1985 in 84 that don't get to
headline anywhere else this is
supposedly the boom right right so
they're willing what year is this 84 85
okay they're willing to come to Madison
Wisconsin right dude seven nights for
$250 plus airfare oh and you get to live
in a student apartment Oh God like a
horrible right and so comics are comics
and so they show up like it's Lou deck
Steve and Ellen green I don't know if
you know these no nobody does and
they're very nice guys and they're very
funny but it would they were also super
new at the time right but bill was like
well we're gonna bring these guys in
and and then Sam was his big headliner
and it was Carla bo and Sam and a guy
named Freddie asparagus and and so
whatever but they were all doing coke
and cheating on their wives
and it was gross yeah my friends were
like there was almost an intervention
like Mike my college friends who I'd
been living because this is 2nd year of
college
yeah and I would come home and I would
tell them what I thought were these
great stories
hilarious great stories about Rodney
Dangerfield at Chris Rock and and and
mobster wannabes and all these dirtbags
and all of my friends in college are
like these are terrible people with
horrible and they're doing a lot of
drugs and booze and they're having sex
with everybody that's gross you gotta
get away from that I was like no no it
turns out I'm willing to hang out with
with the dodgy if I get stage time I
think I might be one of them so when I
graduated from college cuz my sister
told me I had to yeah she is the boss oh
really
1988 I was like okay well now now we're
in now I'm doing comedy except for by
now I didn't know where to go and all of
the other all the comics that I came up
with they all moved to Chicago and
you're only at this club at this point
yeah one club this one club that was the
only Club and I would occasionally get
drive to Milwaukee but I never driver's
license okay and I would occasionally
they would somebody would set up like a
gig out in the Best Western in the
middle of Wisconsin be like weird for
waling kind of situations that was where
the that was where the exactly thing
happened I was on stage and I was just
doing ten and Marmol and Eric Alvarez
liner they were the big dudes right and
there was these two drunk guys in the
front row second row who were heckling
me uh-huh
and so I didn't have a good set right he
was grumpy and I get offstage and and
Steve goes up Marmol and they continue
to heckle me in the audience go to the
bar and I get a beer
sitting there with my mug of beer
drinking it furious at myself and mad at
them one of the guys has passed out on
the table oh good the hecklers the other
guy gets up and stands right behind me
and I make a very mature decision that
if this guy talks to me one more time
I'm gonna throw my beer at him because
I'm not mature and so instead instead of
talking to me he touches me Oh God and
the bartender and the bouncer both say
that he was reaching over my shoulder to
grab my breasts oh my god hilarious and
not okay man but all I feel is you touch
my shoulder yeah and I of course have
already made my mature decision so I
turn around throw my beard up yeah
missing him completely Oh God hitting
the guy behind him full in the face at
which point the heckler picks up that
guy's drink and throws it at me so now
I'm in the middle oh Jesus like a
Western and the heckler guy standing
there laughing laughing laughing
laughing and so I punched him and I
forgot that I was holding the beer mug
so I clocked him with a beer mug nice
this is about six foot tall and I knock
him down because he's not expecting it
and I am the Buddhist craziest woman in
the world that both of these stories for
you this is awesome but he falls down
and then he stands up and starts calling
me a dyke and
and all these war you know yeah and I
again not the hero I say you got a
problem with homosexuality [ __ ] again
the hero we were both ejected from and
it turns out it wasn't a romantic comedy
so we didn't end up married both get
kicked out but curiously here's the
addendum the guy that I hit with the
drink yeah four years later I'm doing a
one-nighter tour the Dakotas okay and
I'm featuring uh-huh and for a guitar
comic Wisconsin and we start telling
each other our heckler stories he tells
me my heckler straight he tells me that
story he doesn't know it's you know the
drink
oh oh that's us and I was like what and
we both have to pull over and find and
because it's 1980 yeah it's 1990 no yeah
must have been 92 or 93 at this time we
pull over and find a payphone he has to
call his wife and say and I have to call
my sister with the drink you know
they're gonna come to pop on Sirius XM
99 I am here with my good pal Jackie
Kashian who has a new comedy collection
coming out called this will make an
excellent Horcrux it's coming out on all
things comedy calm is only gonna cost
you five bucks you've got to check it
out
thank make sure you do that on March 4th
and every day thereafter that's kind of
the cool thing these things last forever
and make sure that you follow me on
Twitter at Tom papa like I said in the
beginning of the show I want to build up
this come to Papa community and I'm
doing my part I'm sending out my voice
through the radio to your minivan or
truck and I want you to pull over and
come back to me vision board let me ask
you this okay
I'm always interested by you I always
want to know how you I always want to
know I'm always I often thinking about
you and how you living your life because
it's because you're my pal and but I'm
also impressed because we do live pretty
different lives you're not doing a big
kid you don't have alright right I don't
have the Ute you don't have a fake
kitchen set in the corner of your thing
oh that's a nice lure children still
against the wall yeah I have a hacky
sack though and what I'm always
interested in what I'm always interested
in is how you get like you always seem
to be tuned into cool things that are
going on and cool stuff that I don't
know about if I were to break open your
computer not your husband's stick one
but if I were to open up yours and go to
you what browser do you use are you a
chrome from your clothes
so what is on your on that on the the
bookwork there chrome my homepage
homepage bbc.com slash news bbc.com okay
i like to get the perspective from a
little outside but not too far out too
far outside still in English not
al-jazeera but I understand that they
are doing actual journalism so it's not
nbc.com or CNN or Fox News yeah I mean
it isn't it's just I like the
perspective from a different country
because and there's always there's but
and then I am currently playing one of
the creepiest I play what I call
middle-aged white lady games right now
uh-huh and it's not just white ladies
it's middle-aged all ladies women of
color are out there playing hidden
object game Susan said I do know my
friends are also playing hidden shadows
is a Zynga game so Zynga is a behemoth
of that people don't like but why don't
they like them because they do a lot of
in game constantly asking you for money
and they're always wanting to know your
email address and they're constantly
they're pretty aggressive my kids got
wrapped into that once super agro they
started all of a sudden I got like a
like a 600 dollar bill know of in-game
purchases in game purchase a political
acts one the next one is on you yeah
either you step up your parenting
techniques or you're gonna be paying for
it right so what is this so what hidden
shadows is a hidden object game there's
another one there's a Disney one that's
pretty good called hidden worlds and
that is for children shadows is not for
children why because it is a murder
mystery it's a murder mystery hidden
thing and the first scene is usually a
body covered in blood with an accidents
head a bullet hole hanging
and but it's like find the golf club
don't find the victim's body first find
the VIN get rid of that other weapon it
isn't the wallet because you gotta find
you know you gotta find eight eight
objects okay so you're like oh look
there's a flower there's a bee a bee but
then how does it relate to the dead
person and then then you find clues you
also find clues but you also have to
find other objects so it's fine the
worst thing about this hidden shadows
thing uh-huh
is that you occasionally find a tool
like a key or a crowbar and then you use
it in the next scene where you have to
curl bar open a thing or you have to
open a locker yeah with the tool the
first time I found a shotgun and then I
had a euthanasia a bad guy I was like I
don't want to play this game anymore and
yet I need to get to the next screen so
allow me to shoot the tide up man
how I am how many hours on this game in
a day in a day in a day um normally a
normal day when you guys use your
property has two three and you're making
a funny face when you say that probably
double that it would be except for that
luckily they do have finite they you
could only do so many oh it's like
reload yeah it's like yes that thing no
no it's actually I love that there's a
yeah because I'm unwilling to pay it
give them a dime right of course because
I bought middle management of justice
that was it was either two or five
dollars right right and there was no
limit uh-huh and I lost work because I
played it forever and I reloaded it to
play it again middle management so is it
it's BBC in all games on that on your I
also enjoy there's a very very dirty
webcomic that I enjoy called ogle off Oh
Glif comm not-safe-for-work the sword &
Sworcery dick jokes welcome so funny so
it is drawn and written by a woman oh
yeah and I bought a hard copy of it
for Andy for his four for Christmas
uh-huh and it came it was it was
essentially the collection up till then
and it came and the the packing slip
just said enjoy your dirty book ogle
Ofcom comes out on Sundays and I
recommend you start from the beginning
because some of them they're just
they're filthy some of them are not
filthy and just funny right and some of
them are both filthy and just and
they're all how'd you find that now this
is this is what I want to know how to
where did you get tipped off on this was
it some cool friend is it Andy reads a
lot of web comics Andy does yeah so
he'll read
he reads something called darth's
Androids which is a recreation of all of
the Star Trek Star Wars movies set as a
role-playing game a tabletop
role-playing game and then he'll sorry
you're in so deep so deep I am doing
this new bit that's super it's on the
new album it'll be in the new special
but it right it's good needs another
year to make it good right now it's just
a huge review is the fact that when I
have when you have sex with somebody all
the time yes and just the one person
this is the most too much info this is
the one the most sex I've ever had with
the same person right I am married yes
we have sex this is my guy this is it
we're a man committed monogamous this is
what's happening so you have a lot of
sex with the one person eventually you
will have a sexual experience with that
person because you're always trying
stuff right where it reminds you of a
bad sexual experience and it will remind
you of a sad thing and then all of a
sudden he is having sex with someone who
is crying you have to laugh at that and
the fact that and and so as a woman of
course you get a couple of choices you
can lie there stoic ly silent tears
coursing down your face while he ruts
like it's a Dickens novel or you could
talk to him like a person wants you to
have a good time
yeah cuz he does everybody wants
everyone to have a good time in the sack
even one-night stand guys were like I'm
leaving but that was a good time so I
did I talked to him and I said ooh hoo
sad thing reminded me I'm gonna need a
minute to regroup right and he goes of
course of course and then later he goes
or we could take back the night we could
LARP it out to live-action role play is
to LARP live-action role plays to larva
yes so what he's like we'll set up a
couple of chairs in the in the kitchen
pretend we're on the bus like where it
happened the horrible thing and then
we'll go through it again right well
reenact it but it'll be with me and will
cry and we'll laugh because here's the
thing when you have a horrible sexual
experience right your body doesn't care
that it's a creepy person doing it to
you your body's like oh six right your
body's like into it yeah because your
body's just physically you're an animal
right like oh right you're supposed to
want this and you're like no sad creepy
thing it's crazy Uncle Tom or whatever
horrible thing that's a guy right and so
then when you're reminded of it your
body reacts again and you're like no but
that was the horrible thing and so that
was that's what makes you cry as you
said right and so he's like so if we go
through it again but it'll be me uh-huh
and you'll like me that's my favorite
line yeah well laughs we'll cry and you
can move we'll have sex right and then
uh and then we'll take back tonight and
it totally worked it did yeah yeah I
thought you were leading to this not
working at all right
which you it could backfire and not
risky for him Toby because he got see
stuff right you're going to be into it
yep you're playing the bad guy he's
playing the bad guy and you know the
truth is he's going to be turned on and
into whatever is going on break his
world noodley right yep and if it
doesn't turn out right now now he's got
now we have to take back Take Back the
Night
you've got to keep you guys in your head
now when he really worked and you cry
and go through all this other stuff it
was I cried we laughed and it was silly
and gross and fun and then in the end I
was like okay well this is a thing and
your head is now different regard to
that experience Wow
yeah and I'm like oh I could love that
and when because when the thing is is
when the when you're a kid or when when
you're when a bad thing happens and you
don't act on it right when you don't go
hey jackass
stop doing that you and you can replay
it and you're like okay well I was a kid
I didn't know how to say hey stop doing
that's right that's actually not okay
but you can do it in the LARPing part of
it right you get some of your power back
and then you also have a realization of
oh I was a stupid I was not a stupid
child but as a child yeah and this was a
bad person so let's you know and then I
take back the night and you're like oh
but I get to like it anyway because
those are those are good feelings it's
the right person do we get Wow with it
pretty amazing
do you think this would work so that's
comedy right so that's that that's a
good premise for some [ __ ] definitely
it's not one that just falls in your lap
you're gonna have to work has to go into
the shop you have to work on this one
the shop the greatest premise the last
time I saw you I loved I don't know if
you're still working on it it's about
how your wife is crazy because you and
your children are driving her crazy and
you said she's the only one who wakes up
and cares immediately what happens the
day then she says has everyone doing the
thing that they're supposed to do and
you all make fun of her ago and we just
woke up were we supposed to start
happens like oh my god that's what
mothers are crazy is because they are
the only ones who care it happened this
morning it happens it happens every
single day every day I'm sitting at
counter reading the paper and the kids
are eating breakfast and mom gets up and
it's like we're all acting like it's
Saturday morning and there's like the
clock is ticking people have to be
dressed in out of the house with lunch
and teeth brushed and all the rest of it
in literally 18 minutes and she's unless
she comes
it's and everyone's like mom mom mom and
I know they look at me like debts just
reading the paper I mean I don't know
why you're going crazy
why are you crazy the greatest line can
I say the greatest okay so is when you
get you know that she loves them more
than you do because you get in the car
yes and like I already missed them and
you say who are you talking I don't even
know who she's talking about all right
before we go okay let's talk one let's
talk about the joke that we shared
what's that one the joke that you and I
shared I mean this is this is this is I
love this that I love telling this
because first of all I've never been
able to tell it yeah but because this
shows you know there's a big thing in
comedy of material and who has the right
thing and certain people have seemed
like they have a similar bit sure it
happened it's this rule writing yeah
this really shows because we love each
other and we know each other for a long
time and we're both artistic and doing
our own thing and always carving your
own path and we I literally did my joke
about but I do about about diabetic cats
yeah and there are certain beats in it
that we said exactly the same yep and
part of it is because it's set up
because that is the reality
cats get I had this joke in my act and
Jackie did too in her act of my wife had
a diabetic cat I have to give it shots
two times a day
and its neck you saying your joke I have
to give them there's my friend give
shots two twice a day twice a day it's
time for a new cat you know twice a day
means time for a new cat time for
you cat yeah I have the same the exact
same beats exact same as the next part
three thousand dollars a year for
diabetic cat medicine three thousand
dollars a year to find out it's still a
diabetic cat right and you know what
that means and you said this three
thousand new cats three thousand I don't
know if I did three thousand you said
three thousand ducats because I had just
on the joke three comics before you and
I had no idea that you did it not been
in the room for that part of my act and
people were like and I'm like why is the
rest of that Senate this joke working I
just said the joke and people are just
staring at me I'm like this joke kills
even if I say it wrong it kills right
and you got offstage and I said three
thousand cats let's see exactly same
jokes I just did three about ten minutes
ago
and you're like so bizarre it was
bizarre so strange yeah and we both have
put it on TV and did our own thing with
it yeah it's a great joke - great - how
bizarre it is crazy it was parallel
writing exec cuz you were like yeah it
just happened and I said it happened two
years ago to my friend that proved to me
without a doubt that that that really
happens and I wonder why I mean for this
one it's very specific as we were both
literally dealing with a person who was
crazy dealing with people with cats but
I wonder what it is about the culture
when everybody starts talking about
certain things at the certain time yeah
is it is it because we're all getting
the input from the same places
it must there's some sort of hive
mentality there definitely is there's
there's certain premises that they go
through like rejuvenations yeah you know
like I I remember many years ago is ten
years ten eleven years ago I had my
civil war joke I was a War Reenactment
joke right and I had not heard anybody
else talking about War Reenactment guys
yeah and then for the following four
years a lot of War Reenactment - yes I
have a joke right now that's on the new
album the new special about comics and
Asperger's right and I have heard three
people in the last four months start
talking about comics and aspects there
are certain times when I get would write
a joke and be like I know it hasn't been
done yet I've got it out there but I'm
like I've got to get this on Conan
or Letterman now because it's come
everyone's it's good it's gonna start
coming yeah and some of its because it's
just easy like a CPS joke or something
like that or its GPS joke I heard me
Bill Cosby yeah so it's just like you
know it just happens and that's the
thing that's why the comedians that
really make it are the ones that are
constantly writing and Jackie is one of
those people she's one of my favorites
March 4th go to all things comedy calm
and pick up this will make an excellent
core crux it's 5 bucks just get it tell
your friends about it follow her on
twitter at ab Jackie Kashian at Jackie
Kashian and I'm Tom Papa we thank you so
much for listening see you next